gençler Merhaba bugünkü dersimizin
konusu sıvı basıncı olacak katı basıncı
dersini iyi öğrenip buraya geçmenizi
tavsiye ederim çünkü orayla bağlantı
kuracağız benzer şeyler konuşacağız
hemen yine sorularla Deneylerle
başlayalım burada bir su dolu şişemiz
var üzerinde çeşitli derinliklerde
delikler açtık ve o delikleri bir bantla
kapattık o bantlı çektiğimiz anda
deliklerden su fışkırmaya başlayacak ama
enteresan bir görüntü elde edeceğiz
deliklerden farklı hızlarda suyun
fışkırdığını göreceğiz en üstteki
delikte daha yavaş çıkıp hemen düşerken
alta doğru indikçe daha hızlı çıkıp daha
ileriye düştüğünü görüyoruz suyun yani
aşağıya doğru indikçe Derine doğru
indikçe suyun çıkış hızının arttığını
gözlemliyoruz bunun sebebi ne olabilir
veya bir su şişesi ile Havuzun dibine
doğru dağıldıkça ki normal bir havuz
değil bu 20-30 metre derinliğinde bir
Havuzdan bahsediyoruz şişenin böyle
ezildiğini büzüldüğünü küçüldüğünü
görüyoruz sanki ayağımızla ezip
yassılaştırıyormuşuz gibi Hiçbir şey
yapmadığım halde Tek yaptığım şey Derine
dalmak olduğu halde şişenin ayağımla
ezmişim gibi incecik kaldığını görüyorum
Bunun sebebi ne bakın şişe küçücük kaldı
ilk Halinden Eser Yok Bunların sebebi
sıvıların basıncıdır gençler Biz bugün
durgun sıvıların basıncına bakacağız bir
de hareketli sıvıların basıncı olacak o
ileride akışkan basıncı olarak
öğrenilecek bizim buradaki sıvılarımız
olduğu yerde duruyorlar bir kabın
içerisindeler ve o kabın içerisinde bir
basınç uyguluyorlar sıvılarda aynı
katılar gibi ağırlıklarından dolayı
basınç uygularlar gençler O yüzden
Havuzun dibine dağıldıkça Üzerimizdeki
su miktarı arttığı için daha fazla
ağırlığa maruz kalıyoruz daha fazla
ağırlık o plastik şişenin küçülmesi
ezilmesi demek o yüzden üstteki delikten
az su fışkırdı alttaki delikten daha çok
su fışkırdı daha hızlı fışkırdı çünkü
alttaki deliğin üstünde çok fazla su var
çok fazla ağırlık var bu ağırlık bir
basınç oluşturuyor o basınç da suyu
hızlı fırlatıyor üstteki deliğin
üzerinde az su var onun ağırlığı az
olduğu için basınca basınca az olduğu
için su daha yavaş çıkıyor delikten Peki
bu sıvıların basıncı nelere bağlı
çoğunuzun belki kulağına çalınmıştır
değil miydi kenarları yerle 90 derece
yapan yani tabanındaki alan Neyse
yukarılara çıktıkça o alan değişmeyen
cisimlerde mesela Küpte mesela
dikdörtgen prizmada mesela Silindirde
katı basıncını bulmuyor muyduk bu
ifadeyle Evet buluyorduk sıvılarda da
bunu aynen kullanıyoruz sıvı basıncını
da HD hesaplıyoruz neden bir kere katıda
mevzu neydi onu tekrar bir hatırlayalım
şöyle bir silindirim olsun katı bir
silindir H yüksekliği olsun R yarıçapı
olsun En kütleli bir silindir olsun bu
arkadaş tabanda yatay zeminde bir basınç
oluşturuyor şimdi basıncın genel ifadesi
nedir birim yüzey alanındaki kuvvet
miktarıdır buradaki kuvvet basıncın
oluşmasına sebep olan kuvvet ki bu
katıdaki ağırlığın ta kendisidir Çünkü
katılarda basıncın sebebi ağırlıktır
ağırlığın var diye zeminde bir basınç
oluşturuyorum Yani ben bu ifadeyi g/a
olarak yazabilirim HD'ye benzetmiştim
Yani işin içerisine özkütleyerek atmam
gerekiyor özkütleye Nasıl dahil edeceğim
ben buraya Özkütle dediğim şey kütle
böyle hacimdir kütleye yalnız bırakırsam
hacim çarpı özkütledir bana ağırlık
lazım yani bu kütleyi ağırlığa
çevireceğim yani Yerçekimi ivmesi
çarpmalıyım ben burayı yer çekimi ivmesi
ile çarparsam eşitliğin sağını da yer
çekimi ivmesi ile çarpmam gerekir Çünkü
orada bir eşitlik var Dolayısıyla
ağırlık dediğim şey vdg geldim Burada
ağırlık yerine hacim çarpı Özkütle çarpı
Yerçekimi ivmesi yazdım bölü alan şimdi
şeklimin kenarları zeminle 90 derece
yapıyorsa yani tabandaki dairenin alanı
yukarıya çıktığımda değişmiyorsa böyle
şekillerin hacimleri nasıl bulunur
geometri dersinden hatırlayın taban
alanı çarpı yükseklikle Bulunur o yüzden
ben buradaki hacim yerine yani V yerine
taban alanı ki o a olsun çarpı yükseklik
başla bulabilirim çarpı cismin özkütlesi
çarpı yer çekimi bölü taban alanı e
burada alanlar birbirini götürdüğü için
basınç dediğim şey neye eşit olmuştu Bu
katıda aştag'ye eşit olmuştu Bu katı
silindirin tabandaki basıncını Ben böyle
bulabilir hocam bunun sıvıyla Ne ilgisi
var çünkü sıvıda da mantık aynı değilim
ki ben şurada bir x noktasının
üzerindeki sıvı basıncını merak ediyorum
e burada yazdığı üzere sıvılarda
ağırlıklarından dolayı basınç
uyguluyorlar Yani bu x noktasında bir
basınç mı var Evet Niye Çünkü üzerinde
bir ağırlığı var ben burada sadece x
noktasını baz aldığım için şöyle hayal
ediyorum bu X'in üzerinde böyle incecik
küçücük bir sıvı sütunu hayal ediyorum
bir silindir hayal ediyorum Aynı
buradaki katı gibi işte x noktasındaki
basıncın sebebi üzerindeki bu sıvı
sütunun ağırlığıdır bu sıvı sütunu H
yüksekliğinde Şuradaki alana da a
diyebilirim burada katı için Yazdığım
her şey buradaki sıvı sütun içinde
geçerli olacaktır katı için bu tabandaki
basınç HG ise o zaman bu sıvının
tabanındaki bu x noktasındaki basınç da
aç DG ile bulunacaktır ne farkı var ki
ister katı olsun ister sıvı olsun Aynı
şey çünkü İkisinde de basıncın sebebi
ağırlık Bu yüzden Gençler biz sıvılarda
da basıncı bulurken yüksekliğe özkütleye
ve yer çekim ivmesine bakarız Ne kadar
derindeysen basınç o kadar fazla
üzerindeki sıvının öz kütlesi ne kadar
fazlaysa O noktada basınç o kadar fazla
yer çekimi ivmesine kadar fazlaysa yani
dünya seni ne kadar güçlü çekiyorsa
basınç o kadar fazla diyebiliriz dikkat
ederseniz burada yazan her şey
üzerindeki sıvının ağırlığını etkileyen
şeyler Derine indikçe üzerindeki su
karartıyor O yüzden basınç artıyor
sıvının öz kütlesi fazlaysa zaten sıvı
daha ağır bir sıvıdır aynı hacimdeki
suyla cıvayı düşünürseniz cıvanın
kütlesi daha fazladır Dolayısıyla
üzerindeki ağırlık miktarı da artacaktır
basınç artacaktır Yerçekimi fazlaysa
dünya senin güçlü çekiyorsa üzerindeki
sıvının sana uygulayacağı kuvvet ağırlık
daha fazla olacaktır Tabii ki Yani
bunların hepsi üzerindeki sıvının
ağırlığı ile ilgili şeyler bakın benim
elimde bir basınç ölçer var tabanda
Hatta şöyle
ızgaralar koyalım tam seviyeler belli
olsun tavanda 131 kilo Pascal basınç var
diyor yukarıya çıktıkça 122'ye düşüyor
biraz daha çıkarsam 112'ye düşüyor yani
H azaldıkça derinlik azaldıkça basınç
azalıyor derinlik arttıkça gördüğünüz
gibi basınç artıyor Üzerimizdeki sıvıyı
Şimdi biz tabanda 131 kilo Pascal var
gibi düşünürsek öz kütlesi bir olan su
değil de bir nokta 4 olan bal yaparsak
basınç da 144'e çıktı arttı özkütlesi
daha küçük bir şey olan benzin yaparsak
122'ye düştü azaldı Çünkü Özkütle
basınçla doğru orantılı artarsa artar
azalırsa azalır Yerçekimini
değiştirirsem de sıvı basıncı
arttığı için H arttığı için derinlik
arttığı için su basıncı artıyor sıvı
basıncı artıyor basınç arttığı için de
şişe iyice küçülüyor Çünkü Üzerimizdeki
su miktarı artıyor en dibe indikten
sonra şişeye dikkat edin gençler
yukarıya doğru çıktıkça haş azaldıkça
Üzerimizdeki su miktarı azalacak su
miktarı azaldıkça bu şişeye etki eden
sıvı basıncı azalacak sıvı basıncı
azalırsa tekrar eski haline dönme
eğilimi gösterecektir gördüğünüz gibi
yukarıya doğru çıkıyoruz ve şişe böyle
yavaş yavaş tekrar şişime eski haline
gelmeye başlıyor bakın iyice yukarı
çıktık O neredeyse iki boyuta inmiş olan
şişe orijinal boyutlarına geri geldi
Bunu zaten günlük hayatınızda da
hissetmiş olabilirsiniz denize
gittiğinizde derinlere daldıkça
kulaklarınızda bir baskı hissedersiniz
ve bu sizi rahatsız eder şişenin başına
gelen şey sizin oradaki kulak zarınızın
başına geliyor Çünkü E hocam bu
katılarla aynıymış diye düşünebilirsiniz
çok benziyorlar ama aynı değiller
katılarla sıvıların bir farkı var
katılar sadece üzerinde durduğu yüzeye
basınç uygularken sıvılar içinde
bulunduğu kabın temas ettiği tüm
yüzeylerine basınç uygular çok mantıklı
bir soru hocam Tamam burada sıvı var
görüyorum burada sıvı olduğunu basıncın
sebebi de sıvının ağırlığı E bu aşağıya
doğru o zaman basınç hep bu yüzeyde
Olmalı tabanda Olmalı yan duvarda niye
basınç olsun ki su Buradan böyle
fışkırıyor yan duvarda da basınç var
Çünkü bu katı basıncı değil sıvı basıncı
Burada da basınç var burada da basınç
var burada da basınç var sadece tabanda
Yok katılardan bu yönüyle ayrılıyor
sıvılar Çünkü sıvılar katılardan farklı
olarak yayılma eğilimi gösterirler
akışkandırlar onları bir hacimde zorla
tutarsın Bir şişenin içine koyarsın o
şişenin şeklini alır Ama o şişeden delik
açarsan hemen çıkmaya çalışır oradan
mesela burada sıvıyla dolu bir kap var
silindir şeklinde de bir sıvımız vardı
Dolayısıyla ben şimdi size desem ki
gençler şu yan duvarları Ben bir anda
yok ettim bu sıvı bu silindir durumunu
koruyabilir mi Hayır koruyamaz ne olur
hemen dağılır hemen bu yüze yayılır
şöyle bütün yüzeye yayılacaktır Bu ne
anlama geliyor Aslında bu sıvının
ağırlığı sadece aşağı iyi değil yanları
da zorluyor anlamına geliyor yanlardan
zorlanıyordu ama kap onu tutuyordu o
kabın yan yüzeyleri ortadan varsa bu
yanlardaki basınçlar yüzünden sıvı
dağılıp bütün yüzeye yayılacaktır
katılarda ise böyle bir şey yok bu
kırmızı silindir bir katı olsaydı kabın
içinde de olsa kendi başına da olsa
Aynen böyle durur Çünkü katılardan
farklı olarak sıvılar üzerlerine
uygulanan basıncı Aynen her yöne iletir
Özellikle bu her yöne ifadesi çok önemli
bakın katılar basıncı Aynen iletmek
zorunda değillerdi bunu çokça konuştuk
çivi örneğinde konuştuk yüzey alanı
değişirse basınç da değişir yani kuvveti
Aynen iletmiştir ama daha dar bir
alandan o kuvvetiyle etmiştir basınç
artmış olur kuvvet sabit alan küçülürse
basınç artar ve aynı kuvveti daha geniş
bir alandan ilettiyse basınç azalır
Çünkü alan büyüdüyse basınç azalmıştır
kuvvet sabitken ama sıvılar öyle
değiller sıvılar üzerlerine uygulanan
basıncı her yöne Aynen iletirler diyelim
ki böyle pistonlu bir sistemimiz var
şurada bir küre var üzerinde delikler
var ve buradaki şu silindir kısmında su
var Ben bu pistonla suyu itersem suyun
sıkışma miktarını ihmal ettiğim için
suyu komple ilerletmiş olurum pistona
uyguladığım basınç bu sıvıyı ilerletir
ve ne olur bütün deliklerden
fışkıracaktır böyle bir görüntü elde
edelim Bu ne anlama geliyor benim
pistona uyguladığım basınç o
silindirdeki sıvı tarafından Aynen
aktarılıyor demek buradaki bütün
delikleri Aynen aktarılıyor ve bütün
deliklerden dik olarak fışkırıyor Çünkü
sıvılar üzerlerine uygulanan bu basıncı
her yöne bütün deliklere Aynen
iletiyorlar elinize bir sünger alın suya
batırılmış bir sünger olsun sıktığınız
zaman sadece Belli bir yerden mi çıkıyor
Hayır her yerinden su fışkırıyor Çünkü
sıktığınızda uyguladığınız basınç o
süngerin içerisindeki sıvıda her yöne
Aynen iletiliyor ve böylece süngerin her
yerinden su çıkmış oluyor sıvıların bu
basınca Aynen her yöne iletmesine Biz
Pascal prensibi diyoruz bizim için çok
önemli bir prensiptir ileride zaten
önemini anlayacağız şimdi bu yan yüzeyde
basınç olma mevzusunu bir de Pascal
üzerinden düşünelim diyelim ki Şuradaki
x noktasında bir basınç var haç
derinlikte olduğu için bu basınca ben
Hast DG diyebilirim Bir de tam şurada
bir yerde y noktası belirliyorum y
noktası da h/2 derinlikte olsun o zaman
diyorum ki bunun basıncı h/2 dg'dir
Çünkü sıvı aynı sıvı sadece derinlik
yarıya indi Peki neden noktasında bir
basınç var çünkü y noktasının üzerinde
de sıvı var bu sıvının da ağırlığı var
işte bu sıvının oluşturduğu basınç
sadece aşağıya doğru değil her yöne
etkiliyor aşağıya aktarılıyor yanlara da
aktarılıyor bu yana da aktarılıyor o
yüzden ben bu y noktasına bir delik
açsam buradan su fışkırıyor Çünkü
üzerindeki bu mavi ile taradığım
bölgenin ağırlığından dolayı olan basınç
sayesinde su fışkırıyor Peki neden bunun
yarısı hocam Çünkü yarı derinlikte
formül öyle diyor mantık nereden geliyor
olabilir çünkü haç derinlikte g kadarlık
sıvının ağırlığı yüzünden basınç varsa
h/2 derinlikte yarısı kadar su miktarı
yani g/2 ağırlıklı sıvının oluşturduğu
basınç vardır O yüzden y'nin basıncı
X'in yarısı kadar oluyor olarak da
düşünebilirsiniz katılar sadece
uyguladığınız kuvvet doğrultusunda
basınca aktarırken sıvılar her yönde
yaparlar bu işi bu çok önemli B
noktasına etki eden sıvı basıncı ile
ilgili ne söylenebilir şimdi söylediğim
zaten ama burada Pascal prensibi'nin bir
sonucu olarak aynı seviyede aynı cin
sıvı içerisindeki noktaların basınçları
birbirine eşittir diye bir not var bu
çok çok çok önemli bir not ilerde bir
sürü soru çözdürecek bize bu Not aynı
sıvıda aynı seviyede basınçlar birbirine
eşittir Bu Pascal prensibi'nin sonucu
Pascal prensibi ile sıvıların Üzerine
uygulanan basıncı her yere iletmesi ne
alaka şöyle bakın B noktasından bir
seviye çektim şöyle bir seviye bu
seviyedeki Herhangi bir nokta ister
Burası ister Burası ister Burası
istersek de B noktası hepsinin
basıncının sebebi üzerindeki bu sıvının
ağırlığı şimdi bu yeşil noktada bu
ağırlıktan kaynaklı bir basınç var ama
az önce söylediğim gibi Bu basınç Her
yere aynı anahtar olduğu için buraya
aktarıldığı gibi B'ye de aktarılıyor
buraya da aktarılıyor buraya da
aktarılıyor aynı basınç Her yer aynı
anahtar olduğu için bu seviyedeki bütün
basınçlar birbirine eşittir ya da
diyebilirsin ki hocam Bunların hepsi aşk
böyle iki derinlikte olduğu için Zaten
hepsinin basıncını aşk böyle 2 DG
yazarım Çünkü bunların hepsi aşk böyle
iki derinlikte Evet ama daha kafa
karıştırıcı yerler var Mesela buraya
inceleyelim iki tane nokta seçiyorum
şurada bir a noktası seçtim şurada bir B
noktası seçtim Az önceki Pascal'ın
sonucuna göre a noktasının basıncı ile b
noktasının basıncı birbirine eşit olmalı
Neden Çünkü seviye çektiğim zaman bunlar
aynı yatay seviyedeler ikisi de aynı
sıvı içerisindeler o zaman basınçlar
eşit hocam bunlar nasıl eşit olsun Şimdi
A'ya baktığım zaman H kadar derinlikte
üzerindeki suya bakıyorum H yükseklikte
su var o zaman ağdaki basınç h'dir ama
B'ye baktığım zaman üzerindeki su
miktarı bu kadar yok şu kadar var bu B
noktasındaki basıncı şu derinlik
üzerinden hesaplamayacak mıyım Hayır
yine bunun üzerinden hesaplayacaksın O
yüzden öğretmenler der ki üzerindeki
sıvıya bakmayın en üstteki seviyeye
bakın oraya göre hesaplayın derler yani
by hesaplarken de şu sıvı seviyesinden
alman lazım derler B noktasının basıncı
da htg'dir Derler ki Gayet doğru
söylerler niye gençler Bunlar eşit olmak
zorunda eşit olmasalardı ne olur diye
konuşalım şurada bir sıvı kütlesi hayal
edin katı bir madde varmış gibi bir
cisim varmış gibi bir sıvı kütlesi hayal
ediyorum burada bu sistem dengede durgun
sıvılardan bahsediyoruz duruyor her şey
ve durmaya devam ediyor Net kuvvet sıfır
diyebiliriz şimdi a noktasında bir
basınç var B noktasında bir basınç var
Ben a noktasındaki basıncın B'den büyük
olduğunu söylesem ne olmasını
beklersiniz cisim duruyor yani o sıvı
kütlesi duruyor sol taraftan fazla
basınç var sağ taraftan az Basınç var
soldan bu zorlanmaz mı sağ tarafa doğru
Evet o zaman bu su kütlesi sağa doğru
akmaz mı Evet akıyor mu Hayır akmıyor
Demek ki soldan olan zorlama ile sağdan
olan zorlama eşitmiş ki duruyor ve
durmaya devam ediyor O yüzden a
noktasında ne kadar basınç varsa B
noktasına da o kadar basınç olmak
zorunda işin mantığı bu ya da Pascal
prensibi aynı seviyede aynı sıvıda
basınçlar birbirine eşittir a ile b aynı
seviyedeler aynı sıvıdalar basınçları
eşittir ya da başka bir mantık Şurayı
düşünelim bu noktadaki Basınç nedir
hocam tabii ki Şuradaki sıvı sütunun
ağırlığıdır güzel diyelim ki bu
yükseklik 10 santimetre Şuradaki
yükseklik 5 santimetre yani derinlik 10
santimetreden dolayı burada 10 Pascal
basınç var şimdi bu 10 pascallık basınç
Pascal prensibi gereğince Sıvının her
yerini Aynen iletilmek zorunda değil mi
Evet yani bu noktada 10 Pascal var ve bu
10 Pascal bu sıvı sütunundan dolayı var
bu 10 Pascal buraya da aktarılmalı
buraya da aktarıl alakalı a noktasına da
aktarılmalı B noktasına da aktarılmalı
bu yüzden bizim a noktamızda bir 10
Pascal var zaten B noktamızda da bir 10
Pascal var Çünkü bu sarı sütun basınç
oluşturduğu ve Aynen aktarıldı A'ya
bebeğe iyi de A'nın üzerinde sadece bu
sarı sütun yok ki şöyle bir sıvı da var
bunun üzerinde 5 santimetre üzerinden
düşünürsen Bu da 5 Pascal demek olsun bu
sütunun ağırlığından dolayı bir 5
pascal'da oradan gelecek o zaman a
noktasında 15 Pascal basınç var aynı
miktarda sıvıdan B'nin üzerinde yok mu
var o da 5 santim değil mi Evet o zaman
bir 5 de ona Gelecek B noktasında da 15
Pascal var basınçlar Ne oldu birbirine
eşit oldu çünkü sıvılar üzerlerine
uygulanan basınca her yöne iletirler ya
da biz bunun sonucu ile ilgileniyoruz
aynı seviyede aynı sıvıda basınçlar
birbirine eşittir Bakın bu bilgiyi
ezbere Herkes bilir ama ben size neyin
nereden geldiğini açıklamasını yaptım
Lütfen burada anlatmaya çalıştığım
şeyleri anlamlandırmaya çalışın üzerine
düşünün Pascal mevzusunu hallettiğimize
göre kabın şekli ve kaptaki sıvının
toplam miktarına basıncın bağlı
olmadığını konuşalım zaten sondaki
şeklin suyunu çıkardık bu mevzu
anlaşıldı 3 kaba bakalım 3 kapta farklı
şekiller var farklı miktarda sıvılar var
Ben bunların tabanlarında noktalar
seçiyorum x noktası y noktası ve z
noktası Bu noktalardaki basınçları
kıyaslamanızı istiyorum hocam burada çok
su var çok su çok ağırlık demek o zaman
Z'de çok basınç vardır hocam burada az
su var az su az ağırlık demektir O zaman
x de az Basınç vardır Hayır sıvı basıncı
H dg'dir Bunların hepsi aynı
derinlikdeler hepsi aynı haç
derinliğindeler Bu bir değişken değil
Hepsi aynı sıvı içerisindeler Bu bir
değişken değil yer çekimi aynı o zaman
bunların hepsi X'in de y'nin de Z'nin de
basınçları birbirine eşittir Çünkü
önemli olan madde miktarı değil önemli
olan derinlik yükseklik Örneğin katı
basıncında da bir saç DG yapıyordu
kesitten şöyle dikdörtgenler çizersem
bir böyle dikdörtgen katı olsun Bir de
böyle bir dikdörtgen katı Olsun ikisi de
aynı yükseklikteler ikisi de aynı
malzemeden yapılmışlar D özkütleri
olsunlar aynı ortamdalar bunların
zeminde oluşturdukları basıncı bulun
desem ne dersiniz İkisi de birbirine
eşittir dersiniz Niye hdg Çünkü ama
basıncın genel formülünden düşündüğümde
ne kuvvet bölü alan derim bu küçük bunun
ağırlığına g dersem bu daha büyük
atıyorum 2G kuvvet daha fazla basınç
daha fazla olmalı ama aynı oranda
buradaki alan a ise buradaki alanın 2A
olması lazım Çünkü özkütleler aynı
hacimler de aynı oranda artmalı
Dolayısıyla alanda iki kat olduğu için
basınçlar eşit çıkıyor ve benzer şey
burada da var Evet burada az miktarda su
var ama bu kabın tabanı da küçük Evet
burada çok miktarda su var ama bu kabın
tavanı da büyük İşin özü bir sıvı
sütununa bakıyoruz x'teki basıncın
sebebi üzerindeki sıvı sütunun ağırlığı
y'deki basıncın sebebi de üzerindeki
sıvı sütunun ağırlığı z'deki basıncın
sebebi de üzerindeki sıvı sütunun
ağırlığı bu üç sütun da Özdeş değil mi
hepsi haş yükseklikli silindirler değil
mi Evet hepsinin taban alanları x yz
noktaları kadar değil mi Evet E o zaman
geri kalan sıvıdan bana ne Üzerimizdeki
sıvı miktarı aynı Bununla ilgili meşhur
bir deneyimimizi izleyelim Pascal
fırçası deneyi Pascal 1700 yıllarda Bu
deneyi yapıyor sıvı basıncının nasıl bir
şey olduğunu derinliğe nasıl bağlı
olduğunu anlatmak için kullandığı bir
deney ağzına kadar dolu damacanamız var
üzerinde de şöyle mavi renkli bir
sıvımız var 1 litre kadar bu mavi 1
litrelik sıvıyı Bu arkadaşın içine
boşaltacağız ve bu patlayacak Normalde
şurada ağzından döksek herhalde bunun
patlamayacağına hepimiz eminiz
sezgilerimize çok aykırı bir durum
olurdu eğer öyle olsaydı ama fiziği
kullanırsak o azıcık suyla bu kocaman
damacanayı patlatabiliriz Bakın bu
damacananın ucuna İncecik bir hortum
bağlanmış bu hortum yukarıya doğru
gidiyor Yukarısı dediğim şey bir
apartmanın artık 10 katımı 15 katımı
bilmiyorum ta en yukarılarda bir
yerlerde bu 1 litrelik sıvıyı o hortumun
içerisine yukarıdan basacağız
Dolayısıyla bu incecik hortumdan
damacanaya bu suyu aktarmış olacağız bu
işleri değiştirir yukarıdan şırıngayla
suyu basmaya başladı hortumu tamamen bu
mavi sıvıyla dolduruyor burada bir
basınç ölçer var basınç ölçerin
yukarıdan o mavi sıvı geldikçe arttığını
görüyoruz ve en nihayetinde bizim
buradaki damacanamız patlıyor o küçücük
suyla kocaman patlattık Hatta renkten
belli gelir gelmez patlatmış sebebi ne
olabilir Çünkü biz Hacı inanılmaz
arttırdık bu mavi sıvının Şu an şu
tabandaki basıncı şu derinlik üzerinden
düşünüldüğünde çok azdır o yüzden en
başta sezgisel olarak koca damacanayı Bu
nasıl Patlatsın diye düşündük Ama ben bu
mavi sıvıyı bu hortumu aktarırsam miktar
aynı miktar sadece ben bunu İncecik bir
tüpe hapsediyorum bunun içerisine
hapsettiğimde aynı sıvıyı bu sefer bu
tabandaki basın çok artacaktır Çünkü
hdg'den düşündüğümde H çok artacaktır O
çok artmış sıvı basıncı da o damacanayı
patlatmaya Yetecektir Hocam yine de bana
mantıklı gelmiyor sıvı aynı sıvı değil
mi miktar aynı miktar kuvvet aynı kuvvet
mevzu kuvvet değil mevzu basınç basınç
dediğimiz şey kuvvet böyle alan bunu
katı içine düşünebilir mi sıvı içinde
düşünebilirim Evet bu 1 litrelik sıvının
ağırlığı Aynı bu değişmedi Ama sen ne
yaptın alanı çok küçülttün İncecik bir
boruya Hapsettin normalde şu kadar olan
alan bu noktaya düştü alan çok küçüldü
basınç çok arttı Damacana patlattı
günlük hayattan bir örnek olarak bir şey
söylemek gerekirse baraj duvarlarını
söyleyebiliriz baraj duvarları aşağıya
doğru indikçe yani tuttuğu suyun Derine
indikçe kalınlaşmak zorundalar
dayanıklılığı arttırmak yani kesit alanı
büyütmek zorundalar dikkat ederseniz
daha aşağılarda daha kalın bir duvardan
bahsediyoruz Çünkü buradaki sıvı basıncı
hdg'den düşünülür H arttıkça basınç
artar ona dayanacak duvarı daha
dayanıklı yapmalısın yani kesit alanı
daha büyük tutmalısın Şuradaki duvarın o
kadar da kalın olmasına gerek yok Çünkü
buradaki husus yani derinlik az Basınç
ve burada dikkat etmemiz gereken önemli
şeylerden bir tanesi de buradaki sıvının
bir önemi yok ne kadar suyu tuttuğunun
bir önemi yok sıvının miktarından
bağımsız burada İncecik bir sıvı sütunu
olsaydı dahi aynı Haçlı bu tabanda
derinde olurdu çünkü biz sadece
basıncını bulmak istediğimiz noktanın
üzerindeki sıvı sütununa bakıyoruz geri
kalan toplam sıvı miktarı Beni
ilgilendirmiyor o yüzden kabın şeklinin
ve toplam sıvı miktarının bir önemi yok
şu kadarlık sıvı için bile bu duvara
gerek vardı çünkü derinlik aynı derinlik
yatay düzlemde durmakta olan sıvı dolu
kabın düşey kesti şekildeki gibidir x
noktasındaki sıvı basıncı p olduğuna
göre y ve z noktalarındaki sıvı
basınçlarını bulunuz tanımlanmış olan
şey x noktasındaki basıncın p olması x
noktası ne kadar derinde H değerinde
buna p denmiş o zaman p dediğim şey ne
demekmiş d g demekmiş y noktası ne kadar
derinde h+h'tan 2h derinlikte o zaman
burası 2h DG sıvı basıncıdır Bu da 2p
demektir Z noktası 1 2 3h derinlikte o
zaman buradaki basınç 3 hdg yani 3p'dir
hocam Şu an saçmalıyorsunuz y'nin
üzerinde sıvı bile yok Nasıl burada sıvı
basıncı olsun Evet bazı fizik
öğretmenleri der ki y'nin üzerindeki
sıvı basıncısı sıfırdır çünkü üzerinde
bunun bir sıvı sütun yok ama Milli
Eğitim buradaki toplam basıncı soruyor
sıvı diye ayırt etmiyor ve ben Pascal
prensibi ile buranın iki ağaç DG
olduğunu size ispatlayabilir bizi
ilgilendiren kısımda burası burada hdg
basınç var çünkü üzerinde bu kadar sıvı
sütunun ağırlığı var Bu da HD basınç
demek Şuradaki kalınlığı ihmal edersek
bu noktada da HD kadarlık basınç vardır
çünkü şu sıvı sütunu hiçbir yere
gitmiyor burada durmaya devam ediyor O
zaman sağında ne kadar basınç varsa
solunda da o kadar basınç olmalı eşit
olmasalar da zaten bu sıvı bir yere
doğru Akardı ya da bir başka deyişle
buradaki h buraya aynen aktarılmış bu HD
Aslında buraya da aynen aktarılıyor yani
burada da şu an HD var bu HD şunun ta
kendisidir Artı bu kadarlık sıvının
ağırlığı da var burada ve o da H
yüksekliğinde Yani buraya bir HD daha
geliyor e toplam Ne oldu toplam iki aştı
oldu yani Bu sütunun ağırlığı artı Bu
sütunun ağırlığı Ama hocam Bunlar alt
alta değiller Pascal prensibi bu basınç
buraya Aynen aktarıldı şimdi burada iki
haçlıg var mı var buraya aktarıldı bu
hikaye buraya aktarıldı buraya aktarıldı
Z'ye aktarıldı Y'ye de aktarıldı ye de
şu an 2 HD var Çünkü buradaki adam
buraya geldi Pascal Prensi yerin
üzerinde sıvı var mı Yok o zaman iki
ağaçta yenge ama Z'nin üzerinde Bak
şöyle bir sıvı sütunu var o da H
yükseklikte yani zaten buradan buraya
bir iki HD aktarılmıştı kendi üzerindeki
sıvının da bir ağırlığı var o da HD
kadar toplam ne yapar Toplam 3 ayda
yapar Dolayısıyla cevabımız 2p'ye 3p
olur Bakın bu soru çok önemli buradaki
hd'leri taşıma işlemim çok önemliydi
bunu Birçok yerde ha bu haç derinlikte
bu iki haç derinlikte deyip geçiyorlar
asıl mantık budur Lütfen bunları iyi
anlayın Birbirine karışmayan iki sıvının
basıncını kap tabanındaki K noktasında
ve H2 yüksekliğin tam ortasındaki L
noktasında inceleyelim Şimdi iki tane
sıvım var Pascal prensibi kullanarak
sıvıların üzerlerine uygulanan basıncı
Aynen her yönde iletmesini kullanarak
kanun ve l'nin basınçlarını yazalım şu
turuncu renkli artık bu hangi renkte
bilmiyorum sıvının ağırlığından kaynaklı
Mesela bu noktada bir basıncı var ne
kadar derinlikte bu H1 üzerindeki bu
sıvı sütunu burada H1 d1g kadarlık bir
basınç oluşturuyor güzel bu basınç mavi
sıvıyı etki ediyor mavi sıvı bunu her
yöne Aynen aktaracak mı Evet mesela
şuraya aktardı mı burada h1d1 g var l'ye
Aynen aktardı mı aktardı o zaman l'de de
H1 d1g var k'ya Aynen aktardım Evet o
zaman k'da da H1 D1 D var fakat kanun
üzerinde bu mavi sıvının da bir ağırlığı
var şöyle bir sütun da var burada bu
silindir ne kadar yüksekliğe sahip H2
Sıvı ne D2 O zaman burada artı h d2g var
işte K noktasının toplam basıncı budur
gençler Peki l'ye bakarsam H1 d1g var
pascal'dan geldi o l'nin de üzerinde
mavi sıvı sütunu var şu kadar da olsa ki
bu tam ortadaymış yani şurası
h2/2'dir O zaman bu sıvı sütunun
basıncını da yazmam lazım l'ye artı h2/2
çarpı D2 çarpı g İşte bu da L
noktasındaki toplam sıvı basıncıdır olay
bu kadar Birbirine karışmayan D ve 3D
özkütlesi sıvılar düşey kesiti verilen
düzgün kaba şekildeki gibi konulmuşlar x
noktasındaki basınç p olduğuna göre y
noktasındaki basınç kaç b'dir hemen
öğrendiğimiz şeyin uygulamasını
yapıyoruz x noktasındaki Basınç nedir
üzerindeki sıvı sütunun ağırlığıdır Hac
derinlikte bu arkadaş o zaman h d g var
çünkü sıvımızın özkütlesi de D kadar
kitap buna p demiş y noktasındaki
basıncı soruyor şimdi önce şu noktayı
hesaplayalım farklı renk olsun bu
noktadaki Basınç nedir bu kadarlık
sıvının ağırlığından kaynaklı bir basınç
var İki haçtan bahsediyoruz O zaman bu
mavi noktada iki haç çarpı D bir basınç
var bu basınç Aynen buraya aktarıldı iki
HD var ama yetmez Neden Çünkü adamın
içinde bulunduğu mavi sıvının da
ağırlığı var Şu kadarlık bir sütun hayal
edin H yüksekliğine sahip o zaman onun
da ağırlığından kaynaklı basıncını
yazarsam H çarpı Bu 3d'lik bir sıvı 3D
çarpı g olur iki aştg 3hg daha Burası
5hd'lik bir basınç demek HDP dediysem o
zaman 5h dy 5p demem gerekir aşağılara
indikçe basınç artıyor aynı dersin
başında izlediğimiz videodaki şişenin
deliklerinden farklı hızlarda çıkan
suların bize söylediği gibi Şimdilik
burada bırakalım video çok uzamasın
plandakinden bir fazla Video daha
çekebilirim yoksa Dersler 1 saatlik
falan olacak makul sürelerde tutmak için
artı bir video yapmamız gerekecek aynı
konuya devam edeceğiz takıldıklarımızı
alta yazın Kendinize iyi bakın görüşürüz
[Müzik]